did you watch the game last night
uh yeah i watched it was i'm proud of
steph curry though i hate both those
teams and also how'd wiggins not get mvp
oh you gotta give it to stephanie they
gave it to steph cause he never got one
before but wiggins
i think so trailblazers one i'm sorry
i'm such an idiot
the one white guys on the lakers yeah i
don't watch a lot of basketball but
that's this is the finals celtics i was
going for steph curry i like steph curry
i said my brother's like
balls deep in basketball like knows
everybody and i was like man i think
wigan should be an mvp and i think he
was the secret sauce to them win this
series and then he goes on this whole
tangent of why it should have been this
other guy i forget what he said oh it
shouldn't have been steph no no he got a
whole different guy yeah he had an
argument for this other guy and i was
like okay well you're too inside
baseball here yeah i don't know i don't
know what i'm talking about i got no
doubt i'm glad steph won and then he
kept like giving me stats i'm like okay
dude and i go hey uh what is your
brother colleges your brothers
don't get an argument with your brother
about sports
he's lost he loves basketball let me run
this by you are you are you about joking
who plays with them yes argue how he's
not better than lebron with him and it's
a knight
joke has won two mvps back to back and
statistically it's like two different
stages you know they're but
you look at the stats it's not jokobitch
or jokes
yeah because um steph curry is probably
the bet the greatest three yeah
already yeah he already and clay
thompson's up there too you kind of you
know he did all right well steph is like
already has all the records yeah but so
my brothers give me all those facts i'm
like yeah no doubt you know you know i'm
a dumbass ago do you think steph [ __ ]
chicks on the road and jay's like what
that's a better thing he gets chicks and
he's like no he's an entourage he's
known for like bringing his wife to all
the games and i was like you're square
and then he just didn't text me back
that's how you put it into it that was a
god you asked about his sexual resume i
was like i'm going to lose on this you
know
he goes no way i go dude a light-skinned
brother mvp superstar charming everyone
knows him he's on a subway commercial
his dad cheated on his mom so he's
already conditioned that yeah what are
we doing here dude let me run eyes
as a lady this girl is a jelly monster
as a girl as a lakers fan i was not
rooting for the celtics i was rooting
for an earthquake just to swallow the
whole stadium and kill all those guys i
hate both those teams but here's i'll
run this by i think i think slam dunks
should be worth three points
or why they're harder than a three-point
shot it's tougher to get there and
they're way more rare
so like now
if you got dorks just shoot because
here's the thing i know that steph's the
best split [ __ ] in the world and i
it's just all the games
because of his
not fun to watch it's like you oh i
disagree it's like ufc when you guys
doing a submission thing it's it's it's
technical and it's really hard to do but
it's also not the most exciting to watch
we want ground and pound
as exciting to watch interesting yeah i
just i appreciate steph cuz he's changed
the game forever and like now kids
are coming up like steph is the face of
like this generation so kids are gonna
be working on their like fundamentals
yeah instead like nobody can relate to
that and remember steph is only six
three at best so like a lot of kids can
relate to him nobody can relate to
lebron lebron
here's the argument for lebron when
people go uh you know michael jordan's
the best magic johnson cream abdul jabar
cool lebron is hands down this is where
the argument is lebron's the best
athlete of all time
i don't think he's a best player you
think he's a better athlete than jordan
yeah really physically not physically
six nine faster 260 shredded it's like
jordan mixed i could have played yeah
he's more like magic johnson than
michael jordan so it's like to be that
big athletic and do what he did at 40
now it's nuts but still doing it nuts on
that level
well that's what steph said recently on
a podcast he was like well any i'm like
he's about hard work so it's like you
can practice your three over and over
you can't practice getting bigger like
you can't make yourself bigger lebron
was born like steph i don't think he was
born with like crazy skills right like
yeah his dad was an mba so he grew up
shooting three pointers in the nba as a
kid which is a huge advantage but lebron
was like
nope like unless you're six nine two
sixty shredded
four four forty yeah we can't relate
somebody said when he was 14 is the best
basketball high school basketball player
in the country at 14 16 14 35.
so he was physically they were
televising his like ninth grade
basketball game my favorite is he like
he pulls up in a hummer hd yeah
it's like well
clearly someone's giving this kid's
money and bought his mom a house yeah
they figured out the serious question no
one cared like that's the future yeah
but i asked my buddy jimmy burke the
serious question i said
when did lebron james
surpass me as an athlete when was he a
better athlete
the real the real question age 10. when
he said he said he's not when he came
here
12 years out of his baby he's a better
athlete [ __ ] out of his mom he's
scientific that's mom's whoo there you
go better athlete